l'ampleur de ces orages est t qu'une
partie de la vallée du rô a donc été
paralysée plusieurs ponts se sont
effondrés dans la région du gare des
déviations ont été mises en place alors
que l'autoroute à 7 on vous l'a dit au
niveau d'orange et l'autoroute à 9 ont
été coupé dans l'après-midi quant à la
sncfl conseille aux voyageurs qui
souhaitent se rendre vers le sud-est de
reporter leur voyage le trafic est
perturbé lorsqu'il n'est pas
complètement suspendu comme à Perpignan
où la quasittalité des trains était
bloqué Séverine lebrin jean-pa chausser
certains attendent depuis des heures
pour rien à la gare de Perpignan
aujourd'hui le trafic était totalement
paralysé au total 10 TGV annul laissant
sur le quai près de 800
passagers ce je l 23h et pu je sais pas
quand demain matin on viendra faire Laue
pendant 2 he parce que là maintenant il
n ILV pas nous dire quand est-ce qu'on
pour
par' tout le trafic àtination de est
interrompu sur le reste des lignes
sud-est la circulation continue mais
avec de nombreux retards selon la SNCF
il faudra un ou deux jour pour mesurer
l'étendue des
dégâts je donne un conseil à ceux qui
peuvent remettre leur voyage de le faire
parce que sinon il risque d'attendre
assez longtemps des trains qui auront de
toute façon des retards significatifs au
sud de Lyon l'autoroute A7 est
totalement fermée à la circulation dans
le sens nord-sud résultat une vingtaine
k de bouchon il était délicat de laisser
les gens s'engouffrer dans la vallée du
rô avec le risque de qu'il soit bloqué
en pleine nuit à
Orange ce soir pour se rendre dans la
région marseillaise il faut faire le
détour à l'est par Grenoble et à l'ouest
par mot mais le plus simple c'est encore
d'éviter de prendre les routes